top gun reveal is this is this dramatic
enough for you guys
[Music]
hey gq it's glenn powell actor writer
producer
and these are my essentials
growing up in austin texas big fan of
music
so
to listen to music i do beats by dre
and this one is customized with my call
sign when i was shooting top gun we were
on all the bases these naval bases are
usually in the desert kind of gross but
i'm a head sweater so this thing you can
sweat all over it and it won't break
down when i'm working out i like to go a
little harder if you're gonna go beats
by dre you might as well
hang out with dre when i'm up in the air
i like a little like willie nelson
something nice and chill something to
put you put you in the right flow i
actually have a top gun
soundtrack
on my phone it's a little embarrassing
not going to get into it but it's a lot
of power ballads
hang man hat
the ultimate essential my buddies at
large lemonade made this thing for me
designed exactly like my helmet the
movie so there was a moment where i
wasn't gonna do top gun i mean it sounds
silly you were not gonna do top gun and
tom convinced me he said hey we're gonna
develop a whole character for you we're
gonna make it iconic it's gonna be the
coolest character in the movie meeting
the original cast they were all like hey
choose your call sign right because
you're going to be called this for the
rest of your life so
that character's hangman and you know i
think the best part about the helmet is
that you can fill in whatever letters
you want
in there any vowel
an a a u
you figure it out
[Music]
okay guys
this is my stetson pride and joy right
here a hat should be a part of you a hat
should compliment
your face it should it should tell you
know people what you care about from
austin texas
you gotta rep boston texas it's better
than an id it's better than a passport
this is all you need you go to my house
in austin you go to my house in la i
have a lot of hats around and the best
part about it is you can get little
custom pieces like this i got a little
g-pin right here
every single one is its own little work
of art its own little piece that
dictates what kind of mood you're in you
know how you wanna you know what kind of
night it's gonna be it's a good time get
a cowboy hat find yourself a tequila
that's all you need
all right let's talk about beach
football montages
and workouts
you can work out in anything but while
you're working out you want to look good
so i like viori because
everything's built in to the pant and it
like dries really really fast so you're
not carrying around
gross soggy stuff all the time and when
you're traveling between different naval
bases you gotta be in montage shape you
never know when tom cruise is gonna bust
out a football scene on you everybody
looks good in vieori ivyori i don't own
vyori but
i wish i did
when life is happening you got to
capture memories but you want to capture
them in the right way two cameras
this is one eric messerschmitt just won
an oscar for mank he recommended this
camera this is the fujifilm x100v great
digital camera this has become my little
baby the best part about it is you know
like when people
carry cameras around especially like
nice cameras you can't share the photos
right so they hold them and they develop
and all that stuff this one you can
bluetooth to all your friends you can
immediately airdrop the photos so you
have high-res photos fixed lens takes
really high-res images this will make
you look good and you'll make your
friends happy because you can share all
the images and then this guy
just a beautiful old school camera like
you were going to disney world 95 very
easy to use but film and you know it's
just immediate nostalgia when you use
this camera a little bit of delayed
gratification you can take this
to you know a place to get developed and
and you see what you got on the other
side but a good way to capture memories
hydration
it's key
this is cactus water i used to be like
all about coconut water coconut water is
like really really sugary cali water
this helps
hydrate you so if you've had a wild
night this is the ultimate hangover cure
helps the skin
it helps brain function also
obviously that's a detox if you want a
retox this is the ultimate mixer this is
the one i love it's the ginger and lime
this goes very well with tequila
and mezcal
so yeah
detox retox talks however you want guys
i don't care
all right magnesium
i love to sleep if you want to go to bed
have a really really solid night's sleep
calm magnesium if you're not sleeping
life's just not as good so you have this
before sleep knocks you right out
magnesium also helps for uh recovery
like if you're doing like really crazy
workouts like on top gun if you get sore
magnesium is the perfect thing to help
recovery i have a little theater in my
house i love watching movies so what
i'll do is i'll do a little magnesium
and hot water and probably get through
about 40 minutes of the movie and then i
will be out like a light you're gonna
need to overdose on magnesium to go to
bed after top gun you're gonna be
thinking about it for a while
[Laughter]
i have a lot of wonderful ladies in my
life my sisters my mom my girlfriend
they introduced me to a great little
skincare routine a little two-stepper by
uh dr dennis gross i travel a lot for
work so i'm always on planes and you
know they're always like trying to take
all the face wash your toothpaste all
that stuff
that ain't gonna happen anymore you
don't need to keep all that stuff on you
you just take one of these things out
rub it on your face take the other one
out rub it on your face
it's easy as that
rob's backstage popcorn
not to name drop here guys but i'm
buddies with jonas brothers every time i
would go backstage one of their shows
their buddy rob literally made this
popcorn by hand now they've actually
officially bagged this stuff so now this
is coming with me everywhere it tastes
like kettle corn but it's really healthy
so it's not gonna
destroy your you know you want to try to
keep a few abs you know in existence so
can't eat popcorn all the time but if
you're gonna eat popcorn rob's popcorn
stuff i'm gonna have some right now
actually
these are my favorite sneakers on
cloudflows i got to travel a lot for
work running on all sorts of surfaces
all around the world these guys
are unbelievably comfortable and they're
super cushiony so it doesn't matter if
you're running on concrete cobblestone
a flight deck anywhere around the world
it all feels good wearing these guys you
know they're also pretty damn stylish
you know you get a lot of compliments on
these look good feel good
cloud flow
i hope you got to learn a little bit
about me through my essentials
until next time